so that's my grand unified theory
of why people hate hyaluronic acid
even though it doesn't really deserve it
it's michelle of lab muffin beauty science
chemistry phd cosmetic chemist and pot stirrer
i asked people to give me their hot
takes and unpopular opinions about
skin care and beauty on instagram and today
i'm going to be responding to a few of these
some body moisturizers are perfectly suitable
for the face i completely agree with this body
and face moisturizers are very similar in terms
of both formula as well as their ingredients
sometimes body moisturizers are made to be heavier
but some people do need heavier moisturizing for
their face the biggest difference when it comes
to formulating a face versus a body moisturizer
is how it spreads with a body moisturizer
you try to make it have a longer spread
versus your face which will have a shorter spread
so what this means is when you're putting it on
your body for example if you don't have a long
enough spread then it feels like your hand just
sort of keeps stopping along your skin you might
have noticed this if you're trying to use up
a face cream on your body it just doesn't
quite feel like it's spreading quite right
but this isn't always an issue so it
really depends on the product itself
and what your skin needs and yeah
body moisturizers will probably work
skin care is unnecessary and our skin will balance
itself out if we leave it alone okay this i think
is definitely true for a lot of people but
definitely not true for a lot of other people
if you're lucky enough to have skin that looks
after itself then good for you but there are lots
of things that can make people's skin just not
look after itself properly for example dry skin
is very heavily genetic things like producing too
much pigment having acne hormonal issues like pcos
can be a cause of acne as well you could argue
that your skin has evolved to look after itself
over millions of years but at the same
time we're in this period of rapid change
where we've changed the climate where we're even
sitting in things like we're near air con or we're
under heater a lot of us are not living where
our ancestors evolved your skin also changes as
you age things don't work quite as well and yeah
again evolution hasn't really caught up to that
now there are definitely some people who are using
skin care and they find that their skin gets worse
because you're messing with something that you
shouldn't be for example i think a lot of people
are probably using moisturizer even though they
might not need it their skin is producing enough
oil and water and they're just using it because
they feel like they should be but a lot of people
do need skin care to keep their skin healthy and a
lot of people might not necessarily need skin care
but after using the right products
they do see their skin get healthier
physical exfoliation is terrible for sensitive
skin i disagree with this there is a lot of
slander about physical exfoliation online and i
need to defend it how harsh physical exfoliation
is depends a lot on what exfoliant you're using
and also how hard you're pressing and also how
long you're using it for something like an apricot
scrub with walnut shell in it or pumice in it
is going to be on the harsher end and that's
usually what people think of when they say
physical exfoliation and a lot of people who
aren't quite into skincare or they've just
started getting into skincare do you tend to use
harsher scrubs and in that case i do agree that is
really bad for sensitive skin it is not going to
make your skin any better it will make your skin
worse almost for sure a lot of these people
are better off chucking that scrub in the
bin but gentle physical exfoliation actually
has some benefits over chemical exfoliants
first off physical exfoliation only happens on the
surface and so you're not risking anything deeper
in terms of irritation if you keep it very very
gentle on the top you also get immediate feedback
on when to stop so if you're putting on say a
chemical exfoliant and then you go off you don't
really notice that you've got it on for too long
or if you're using something too harsh until it's
kind of too late to stop like you can wash it off
but a lot of it has penetrated and will keep on
working after you've washed it off with physical
exfoliation you stop and the exfoliation stops
there's also the fact that physical exfoliation
isn't like ingredients it doesn't have anything
that goes deep into your skin and so there's
going to be less potential irritants and allergens
so i think really it's about getting to know these
gentler forms of physical exfoliation so there's
things like washcloths peeling gels which are some
of my favorite products peeling gels have usually
cellulose or some sort of carbon in it that will
bunch up and it turns into very soft scrubbing
grains so sort of like a scrub except instead of
harsh particles you have these soft little almost
like fibers of fabric except not fabric i find
that they work really well and if i use chemical
exfoliation without also using a peeling gel
then my skin just isn't quite as good there's
also konjac sponges which i think have gotten
less popular but i think it's quite sad because
they are actually really awesome they're like
these soft little jelly sponges that exfoliate
really gently i have an exfoliation guide that's
linked in the description so check that out if
you're looking at other ways of exfoliating so
i think people do tend to over focus on chemical
exfoliation but there's a lot of other methods
as well so physical as well as enzyme exfoliants
which can be really good if you use them all
together not over exfoliating in your routine
hyaluronic acid is overrated can cause
inflammation hope the trend should be
over because it's everywhere okay i do think
hyaluronic acid is maybe overrated and it is
maybe everywhere but i also see a lot of these
sort of fear-mongering myths around it so yeah
let's talk about this whole inflammation thing
there are zero studies showing that hyaluronic
acid in skincare is inflammatory when you put it
on your skin there's actually some studies that
find that hyaluronic acid is anti-inflammatory
when you put it on things like wounds it also
doesn't make a lot of physiological sense that it
could be inflammatory when you put it on your skin
in a skin care product so the reasoning is there
is hyaluronic acid in your body in a lot of places
specifically in your skin it's in the lower layers
and it's called a gag hyaluronic acid is like a
long polymer and when it breaks then your body
senses these smaller particles of hyaluronic acid
and it senses that something is damaged and needs
to be repaired so these little particles can
signal that you need to create some inflammation
for repair but when you're using it in skincare
you put it on the top of your skin the top layers
of your skin are dead and your skin doesn't let in
large molecules in very deeply there's this very
rough rule of thumb that molecules have to have a
molecular weight that's smaller than 500 daltons
to absorb deeply into skin there are exceptions
to this but if you go off and look up buying very
low molecular weight hyaluronic acid it is around
10 000 daltons which is 20 times bigger which
means it is very unlikely to penetrate on top
of that hyaluronic acid is really water soluble
and things that absorb deeply into skin need to
be a good balance between water and oil soluble
before they can absorb deeply because your skin
is both oily and watery it doesn't let anything
very far on either end of the spectrum through
very easily so it's just really unlikely that
even very low molecular weight hyaluronic acid
is going to absorb deep enough to trigger any
sort of inflammation this is like the same
sort of reasoning for why collagen creams don't
really add to the collagen in your skin because
it's just too big it doesn't absorb deep enough
this is a really common problem in skincare a lot
of these studies that are showing the mechanism
how an ingredient could potentially work in skin
doesn't take into account the pharmacokinetics
which is whether or not that ingredient
actually can get to where it needs to go before
working also a lot of products get clinically
tested before they get launched so this is things
like checking if they actually cause inflammation
this is especially the case when it comes to those
really big drugstore brands that have really big
research teams they're always really careful about
releasing products that cause inflammation because
so many people will just go to the supermarket
and pick them up and start using them and enough
of these brands have been using hyaluronic acid
for decades that i just don't think it's a big
concern they wouldn't be using it if they were
like consistent signs of significant inflammation
okay more hyaluronic acid slander hyaluronic
acid dries the skin more if you don't use it
properly and live in a dry climate i don't
even like hyaluronic acid that much but
i need to defend it i've seen this and versions
of this with other humectants for basically
all 10 years i've been talking about
skincare this has even been mentioned
in lots of peer-reviewed studies as well
as dermatology textbooks now i have been
looking at this for a really long time and
a lot of my scientist friends have as well
and every time we try to trace it back to where
they got this information from so we look up
the references that they reference we look up
that reference see who they reference and then
just try to trace it back it always ends up as
a study which doesn't actually have a reference
or it's not actually on skin or it's just not
correct so as far as i know and as far as all
the scientists i've talked to seem to know there
is no actual evidence of this happening on human
skin i think this comes from studies where they
put hyaluronic acid on a relatively small thing
so like a piece of glass for example and they
put it in a controlled chamber which has a set
humidity and temperature and the hyaluronic acid
dried out but skin is very different from a piece
of glass your deeper layers of skin have up to
about i think 60% water and it keeps on getting
more and more water from your blood which is
flowing through like the blood vessels oh yeah
the blood vessels keep on supplying water to the
lower layers of skin which slowly come up through
the top these lower laser skin have so much more
water than air these percentages i'm talking about
aren't the same as the relative humidity so even
if the air has a hundred percent relative humidity
there is still way way more water in your skin
so humectants are always getting most of their
water from your skin and never from the air
there's also water evaporating from your skin
all the time this is called trans-epidermal water
loss so the hyaluronic acid and other humectants
can catch onto this water now i think with how
people use them then there is a good point there
some people are using hyaluronic acid pretty much
on its own thinking it is so great at hydrating
and it's just not very well rounded if you're
trying to moisturize your skin you can't really
just use one humectant it's much more effective
if you also have occlusives and emollients to get
well-rounded hydration like having all three of
those main categories of moisturizer there's also
the fact that hyaluronic acid doesn't work as well
as some other humectants like glycerin glycerin
works in several ways it doesn't just hold on to
water it also can go deeper into skin and change
how the skin's water gets distributed so maybe if
you're comparing hyaluronic acid to glycerin then
your expectations are just a bit too high there's
also the fact that if you have larger molecules of
hyaluronic acid it tends to sit on top of skin and
it forms a film and when that film starts to dry
and settle and turn into a film then you can feel
it on your skin and it feels a bit like your skin
is tight and dry so that's my grand unified theory
of why people hate hyaluronic acid even though
it doesn't really deserve it if anyone has any
leads or solid evidence on hyaluronic acid being
inflammatory in your skin or drying
out skin then please send them my way
vitamin c is overrated antioxidant love
superoxide dismutase pygnogenol resveratrol
okay i have a problem with this i'm a big fan of
vitamin c i've seen people say similar stuff about
how you can just replace vitamin c with other
antioxidants problem one is antioxidants aren't
all the same antioxidants are ingredients
that can neutralize free radicals but they
have different abilities to neutralize free
radicals there are lots of different free
radicals and yeah different antioxidants can
react with different ones to different extents
also most antioxidants have actually only been
tested in vitro so you don't know whether or
not it will actually get into skin to where
it needs to be to actually work and do what
you needed to do the reason vitamin c has such
a good reputation is that it has the most robust
amount of evidence for being an antioxidant in
skin for example there's the studies where it's
reduced sunburn there's also a whole bunch of skin
model studies which aren't quite as good as actual
clinical trials on humans but there's still a lot
more in vitamin c than every other antioxidant
so for example for the antioxidants they've named
here there are no peer-reviewed clinical trials on
actual human skin with pycnogenol or resveratrol
in skincare so placing it on the skin there are
some supplement trials but supplements are very
different from skin care superoxide diss me taste
there is a study on that for each but it doesn't
seem to be working via its antioxidant effect
so yet the level of evidence for vitamin c versus
everything else is just not the same problem two
is that vitamin c is much more than just an
antioxidant it also boosts collagen and it reduces
pigment and those two actions don't look like
they're just because of its antioxidant effects
now i do understand when people can't use it
many formulas of ascorbic acid on the market
are quite irritating and so you can use
some other ingredients instead to get your
i guess overall goals and lack of evidence doesn't
necessarily mean that something doesn't work
and maybe you just personally get better results
from products that have these ingredients and not
vitamin c but saying that these ingredients can
be compared to vitamin c as an antioxidant is
yeah there's just not that much evidence for
it i really don't think they're comparable
what western consumers buy as k beauty isn't
authentic compared to what's sold in korea yeah i
agree that this is probably true but i don't know
if it's really a problem i think authenticity just
for the sake of authenticity is really overrated
so i'm chinese and i don't know a single chinese
person who thinks sweet and sour pork is better
without the pineapple western taste isn't the
same as korean taste so for example those tone
up sunscreens they purposely have a little bit
of white cast because in korea people like to be
a little bit whiter when they put on their makeup
but i don't want it i don't want to look whiter i
don't think most western consumers want it either
i guess if your reason for liking k-beauty is
that it's exotic and you're into korean stuff
or you think that korean people are magically
wise when it comes to skin care then
yeah maybe you should look up the best sellers
in korea and use those rather than what's being
shown by western influences but in reality
the korean bestsellers are also susceptible
to a lot of marketing for example right now the
ewg is a really big thing in korean marketing
and as you hopefully know from watching my
channel their stuff is just complete pseudoscience
it's okay to miss a day of wearing sunscreen yes i
completely agree with this getting really anxious
about missing a single day of sunscreen
is usually not really worth it obviously
i'm not talking about like a 12-hour day where
you're running around on the beach and getting
massively sunburned that is probably not a good
idea and if you are getting severely sunburned
you are increasing your risk of skin cancer but if
you're just having very low uv exposure that day
like maybe you're going to the office or you had
a short walk in the winter then it's probably fine
you've probably skipped a lot of days of
sunscreen before you discovered skin care
one extra day of skipping it is not going to
set you all the way back if you do find yourself
skipping a lot of days though then it might
be good to consider if you have a backup plan
it might be good to think about how you can
develop a habit of wearing sunscreen you might
want to keep some sun protective clothing in
your car or keep sunscreen in your handbag
just as much misinformation
comes from chemists as well
i think this comment is saying
compared to dermatologists
and i would disagree not because i think
chemists are more correct or right all the time
but just because there are a lot less chemists
saying things on large platforms i have definitely
seen some chemists saying very incorrect
stuff in magazine articles and on social media
i actually read a bunch of sunscreen magazine
articles recently for an instagram post
and it was pretty bad but for every chemist i
came across who was interviewed there were like
25 dermatologists interviewed so just based on
the volume alone i don't think it is possible
for chemists to be contributing as much to
misinformation but i definitely agree with
the sentiment of this opinion you shouldn't
trust information just because it comes from
someone with a qualification including me
you should be checking against other sources
i'm sick of single star ingredient products
honestly me too i like a well-rounded
multi-functional skincare product i'm
a bit of a minimalist and i like having less
products in my routine if i can get everything
i want in the one product then i'm going to use
that product i do think single ingredient products
are quite good because they're customizable so
if you have particular allergies or particular
sensitivities you can avoid ingredients you
don't like or at least you can avoid them
more easily you can try an ingredient on its
own and get an idea of how that works although
even then it doesn't give a great indication for
example with niacinamide my skin didn't really
love the ordinary's one but it really liked the
paula's choice product so i actually gave up on
niacinamide at the start because the single
ingredient one was the first one i tried and
it just didn't seem to do much it was just that
particular product just wasn't formulated in a way
that was going to help my skin so i can understand
why people like single ingredient products but
i personally would much prefer a well-rounded
product that has a bunch of suitable actives and
yeah i'm much more likely to use that but at the
same time it can be hard to find a well-rounded
product that fits all of your criteria
there is a lot more trial and error involved
i hope you enjoyed this chat leave me your
unpopular opinions in the comments and maybe
i'll use them in a future video like subscribe
follow more videos are popping up around me